well how is your prep for the tokyo
olympics going
oh it's good i mean we are in like full
prep mode and um you know on the field
every single day getting ready and
obviously you know looking forward to it
so much and for me i kind of get a
second chance because it would have been
really close after having my daughter
last year so now pushing it to this year
i'm really excited for that second
opportunity yeah silver lining um so you
have a great new project that i want to
talk about it's called together can you
tell everybody a little about it
yeah absolutely so together is a media
company that myself chloe kim simone
manuel and sue bird co-founded and it is
a media company that really wants to put
out stories and
inspire young women with these amazing
stories from female athletes we've also
included culture and fashion into
that sport lifestyle so i feel like it's
just all about like empowering and
encouraging and motivating um girls and
women to do whatever they want to do you
know to go after their dreams and goals
absolutely
[Music]